ernest pignon ernest est un artiste à
part dans le monde de l'art contemporain
on y va depuis 1966 il métamorphose les
murs des grandes villes avec ses dessins
grandeur nature d'hommes et de femmes
qui semblent surgir sans crier gare des
ombres qui se fondent dans les rues du
monde entier et se font l'écho des
événements qui s'y sont déroulés ces
oeuvres prennent vie sous son crayon et
son pinceau de cole longtemps naples a
été sa ville de prédilection
une fois adapté un type qui me vient
c'est toi qui fais ça tu sais ces images
on dirait qu'elle soit des murs voilà et
il ya un peu de ça mais images des
images que je colle dans les villes
c'est un peu comme si elle faisait
revenir à la surface c'était comme un
révélateur comme faisait à réapparaître
à la surface des murs ce qui
potentiellement ayez quoi l'univers de
pignon ernest c'est donc la rue où rien
n'est laissé au hasard
quand je fais des dessins ou les
sérigraphies je sais exactement où je
vais les mettre c'est à dire que ça
fonctionne pas comme des affiches on va
coller comme ça je les mets en relation
avec un lieu avec une couleur avec un
souvenir avec l'histoire d'un bâtiment
voyez je suis dire mes dessins il laisse
complètement de ce que je connais des
lieux offrir une oeuvre sur le mur d'une
ville entraîne l'interaction avec toute
la vie autour elles sont inévitables
dégradation et ça l'artiste a bien en
tête
tuner fm c'est une oeuvre éphémère
tout mon travail est bâti là dessus mais
mené la dégradation fait partie de la
proposition cette disparition sa
fragilité aussi c'est à dire que
oui c'est pas une oeuvre qui prétend
traversé les siècles mais probablement
c'est témoigne de notre époque ce n'est
pas un hasard je suis pas le seul
artiste contemporain qui fasse des
oeuvres éphémères et quand l'état
français l'appel pour célébrer la
résistance alors il répond oui en
artiste engagé
dernier exemple en date et portraits des
quatre résistants entrée au panthéon en
2015 moi je fais d'habitude un travail
très très indépendante peu sauvage qui
va la semaine dernière chocolat encore
des images dans les rues de rome la nuit
voyez je veux dire sur pas aux lignes et
sa vie son oeuvre sa mort voilà donc
mais là ces quatre personnalités que
j'admirais beaucoup et nous laisse un
héritage extraordinaire ces gens là
jusqu'au 15 janvier 2023 ernest
pignon-ernest présente à landerneau dans
le finistère l'ensemble de son processus
de création
[Musique]